[Music]
on this Friday night the federal plan to
mobilize production of vital supplies
hand sanitizers face masks and
ventilators to be produced in Canada our
health care professionals really need
support plus the growing fears of
Canadians stranded abroad livelihoods
and companies on the line in Canada and
around the world
the UK's bold plan to pay the wages of
workers plus first-hand experience with
kovat 19
unfortunately stories of heartache and
oh and singing their praises promise me
your lone star honouring the heroes on
the front lines of this pandemic global
national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we know all of you are having to adapt
your lies to cope with this pandemic and
we are too I'm now working remotely
broadcasting from a balcony in North
Vancouver near my home that's downtown
nice and sunny behind me all of us at
Global News are social distancing
because of copán 19 now to the major
developments all the provinces except
one have declared either a public health
emergency or a state of emergency US
canada border closes at midnight tonight
and here's the big picture on numbers
there are now more than 260,000 reported
cases of kovat 19 around the world there
are more than 11,000 deaths and those
numbers are rising by the minute
in Canada 12 people have now died from
the virus there's also a Canadian who
died in Japan after traveling on the
diamond Princess cruise ship in terms of
cases today we hit a grim milestone more
than a thousand people have now tested
positive in Canada that includes at
least 11 who have recovered the bulk of
the cases are in BC Ontario Alberta and
Quebec there were 77 new cases in BC 50
in Ontario 49 in Alberta and 18 in
Quebec every province has detected the
virus now though there are no confirmed
cases in the three territories officials
there have joined every province except
Nova Scotia in declaring either a public
health emergency or a state of emergency
now those declarations mean different
things depending on the region but
generally they give officials more
powers to protect the public just today
Saskatchewan announced that anyone in
that province who violates the
self-isolation orders will be fined
$2,000 the federal government could also
invoke the Emergencies Act giving it
sweeping powers that has not happened
yet but Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
says nothing is off the table for now
he's urging Canadians to stay home to
help slow the spread as Mike Armstrong
reports the federal government is
supporting Canadian manufacturers to
adjust and accelerate production of
medical supplies it is an
all-hands-on-deck call from the federal
government any company that can help
with the fight against Kovan 19 is being
asked to step forward who want to be
over-prepared
and one of the ways to do that is to
build domestic capacity and mobilizing
our industry to do so Canadian companies
that manufacture things like masks glove
and ventilators are being told to ramp
up production
meantime companies in other industries
are being asked to look at retooling can
they shift to making medical supplies
the list of needed products is long and
there's competition to buy them every
other country in the world that is
preparing like ours is trying to get
those items - after days of intense
negotiations Canada and the US have
agreed to close the border effective
tonight at 11:59 Eastern any travelers
trying to cross for tourism or
recreation will be turned around trade
and commerce will continue keeping
supply lines open and food and medicine
moving is a priority truckers entering
the country don't have to self isolate
they are however being watched
they are routinely being checked as they
cross the border to determine if they in
fact are symptomatic another change to
the border is at Rock Sam Road the
irregular crossing south of Montreal
Canada and the US have agreed to
temporarily start turning back asylum
seekers handing them over to u.s. Border
Patrol now the government is still
scrambling to bring stranded Canadians
home there are fewer and fewer flights
from some countries and from others none
getting a plane in to pick people up
isn't easy some countries are locked
down we will have more details to share
but the first flight will be picking up
Canadians from Morocco this weekend this
has been a very rough week for the
airline industry flight crews are
working under very difficult conditions
wondering if they're putting their lives
in danger I spoke to a Canadian crew
overseas today they went last night
taking Europeans home they'll come back
this weekend with Canadians but while
they were there today they got their
layoff notices by email Donna
very tough times Mike Armstrong in
Ottawa thanks ramping up testing is
critical it's the only way to know how
widespread the virus really is federal
money is supporting an Ottawa company
that is developing a portable diagnostic
device that if successful would provide
rapid test results for kovat 19 if
successful is diagnostic Platt
in Cova 19 tests could be used in
airports and in clinics the device could
read the test result within potentially
30 minutes getting more tests including
one for antibodies to this virus so we
know who has had it and recovered is
going to be key to keeping people at
work having so many people at home
unable to work will have an economic
impact unlike anything this country has
ever experienced David Aiken joins me
down David what are analysts saying
about how bad this could possibly get
well Donna Canada was in an economic
expansion that was its longest in
history produced an unemployment rate
that was the lowest in generations and
now forecasters believe we are about to
have an economic contraction that will
be the steepest in our history possibly
producing unemployment rates we haven't
seen since the 1930s
Canada's flagship airline Air Canada is
telling 3,600 flight attendants to stand
down there will be no work for them in
April at Air Canada's Rouge airline all
flights are grounded next month putting
more than 1,500 out of work in
businesses large and small in dozens of
different sectors and in all regions of
the country
employers are simply unable to keep all
their employees on the payroll the
result more than 500,000 applications
for employment insurance this week alone
by comparison just 27,000 filed for AI
in the same week last year I know people
are anxious to get the help they deserve
and our government is working as fast as
possible to support them this is of
course an unprecedented situation and
it's putting a lot of pressure on our
system but we're on it the national
unemployment rate was just five point
six percent last month it is easily on
its way to 8 percent now and may climb
higher one key focus Canada's oil and
gas sector it directly employs nearly
70,000 in Alberta Saskatchewan and
Newfoundland and Labrador and employs
hundreds of thousands indirectly across
the country Global News has learned that
federal officials their provincial
counterparts and some
the country's biggest energy companies
are frantically working on a support
package to literally save the oil and
gas sector the way the auto industry was
saved during the 2008-2009 fiscal crisis
and sources close to the talks say this
is a Team Canada approach to saving the
industry that could yield a rescue
package valued at fifteen billion
dollars or more and all sides say they
hope to hammer out a deal in days Donna
David akin in Ottawa thank you and well
if so many Canadians are losing their
jobs because of Kovach 19 Walmart Canada
is hiring 10,000 workers to meet a surge
in demand the retailer says it needs
more staff in its stores and
distribution centers jobs ranging from
sales associates bakery workers cashiers
and overnight workers some grocery
stores are taking measures to provide
some separation from customers and staff
Sobeys and Safeway have ordered
thousands of plexiglass screens to be
installed at their checkouts
physical distance does slow the spread
but the World Health Organization stress
to gain today countries need to go after
the virus itself tests people find
patients trace contacts isolate and
quarantine in the United States the
restrictions there are ramping up though
public health experts say it's not
happening fast enough the us-mexico
border is closing to all non-essential
travel and two of the largest states
California and New York State are
effectively shut down President Trump
has been touting an anti-malarial drug
as a treatment for Coll vid 19 it hasn't
been approved for use for that by the US
FDA and today the director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases was asked if it
might be effective as a treatment he
said no is anecdotal it was not done in
a controlled clinical trial so you
really can't make any definitive
statement about it may work may not work
I feel good about it that's all it is
just a feeling you know I'm smart guy I
feel good about it and we're gonna see
you're gonna see soon enough there are
now more than 15,000 confirmed cases of
kovat 19 in the u.s. more than 200
Americans have died as our Washington
bureau chief Jackson prosecco explains
that country is on track towards what
happened in Italy
as New York California and Illinois
closed businesses and tell people to
shelter at home the US is telling all
travelers to stay away closing both the
northern and southern borders to all
non-essential travel a move coordinated
with Canada and Mexico that will last
indefinitely we want to make sure that
cargo continues trade continues health
care workers continued to be able to
traverse that border but tourism some
recreational activities and other things
need to stop during this crisis
President Donald Trump insists there's
no talk of a nationwide lockdown at
least not yet
but the u.s. remains on the same grim
trajectory as Italy
the number of cases effectively doubled
overnight the number of deaths climbed
above 200 where you say to Americans
we're watching you right now you're
scary
I say that you're a terrible reporter
that's what I say nationwide there's
criticism that testing is still too hard
to access and confusion as to whether
the president has as he has claimed
ordered companies to ramp up production
of masks and ventilators to meet a
nationwide shortage who's going to take
care of the patients this is a this is a
national emergency
there's also simmering controversy in
Washington several US senators are now
under fire for selling off millions of
dollars in stock holdings before the
markets tanked some attended a
classified briefing on the threat of
coronavirus in February a trillion
dollar economic rescue package also
hangs in the balance
we need a full unemployment insurance so
that when you're laid off you get paid
your full salary you can get on
unemployment quickly as life grinds to a
halt it's now an anxious waiting game as
America waits to see if these
unprecedented measures will stave off
disaster
Jackson prosto Global News Washington
and now to Europe Italy has reached
another grim milestone more than 4,000
people have died there now the most of
any country and in the past 24 hours
alone 627 people died the rest of Europe
is struggling to deal with the virus -
as Redman Shannon reports the UK is now
taking extraordinary measures to protect
its people and the
this is social distancing London style
crowded lineups of grocery shoppers but
everything is about to change in the UK
schools closed on Friday two weeks after
Italy and almost everything else will
soon be suspended including the British
pint tele cafes pubs bars and
restaurants too close tonight as soon as
they reasonably can it will be weeks
before we know if it's too little too
late but the British government believes
extraordinary financial measures are
also needed government grants will cover
80 percent of the salary of retained
workers up to a total of 2,500 pounds a
month that's more than four thousand
dollars the immense catastrophe
unfolding in Italy is what the world is
trying to avoid but these scenes are
almost certainly coming to much of
Europe now the Army has been deployed to
enforce the lockdown in Italy's lombardi
region
and these are some of the efforts in
Spain as the death toll their tops 1,000
if Europe and its wealth appears
powerless against this hidden enemy than
the developing world
Mayfair even worse the virus is now
taking hold across Africa where public
health systems are especially weak it's
hard to avoid social social distance
it's very hard in Africa as part of us
encouragingly China has slowed cases to
a trickle but Hong Kong has seen its
largest daily increase since the
outbreak began most cases are residents
returning from abroad including skiers
who had visited Whistler in British
Columbia a reflection of how this
pandemic is now moving in every
direction Redman Shannon Global News
London
stranded anxious and demanding action
coming up Canadians stuck abroad and
desperate for a way home
the federal government estimates about 3
million Canadians work and live abroad
at any given time many of them have come
home others are desperately trying to
get back now the Prime Minister insisted
today the government is doing everything
it can to help
as Ross Lord reports Canadians stuck
overseas want immediate action for
Chelsea Widdicombe a vacation has become
an ordeal she and her friend Clifford
Robinson flew from Ontario to Peru on
March 11th when they learned how bad the
corona virus outbreak was becoming they
tried to shorten their stay rebooking
the next available return flight for
March 18th but on the 16th Peru closed
its borders what we're really hoping for
as at the Canadian government plane for
the hundreds of Canadian travelers here
group I have to get home before the
situation of all I even more than it
already is they're afraid they don't
speak the language
and they're running out of supplies they
wonder why other countries have picked
up stranded residents in Canada is not
we stay here the worse it's gonna get
just they're gonna restrict us more I
don't know if it's gonna I think it'll
just get harder to bring us home the
longer we stayed here these three
backpackers from Halifax including two
firefighters are also stranded they're
holed up in a hotel room resisting the
urge to panic as police officers and
soldiers enforce Peru's martial law
forcing everyone to stay inside The
Situation's changing on a daily basis
the first day we were able to go in
public and go grocery shopping second
day not really permitted unless you're
by yourself and the situation is getting
ever more restrictive the federal
government says it's doing its best to
bring Canadians home we're in discussion
with Canadian Airlines to help Canadians
stranded abroad come home we will have
more details to share but the first
flight will be picking up Canadians from
Morocco this weekend but a statement
from Global Affairs suggests Canadians
stuck in countries whose borders have
been closed might be forced to wait
indefinitely
Ross Lorde global news stories of sorrow
and survival I had the victims of kovat
19
most people who get kovat 19 do recover
and will hear one person's story tonight
but a beloved grandmother and a vibrant
51 year old father are among the first
Canadian victims of the virus and their
families are now sharing their grief
Heather Eurex west reports shawn cunning
tintin feeling sick for several days but
when he sought treatment at a hospital
in Milton Ontario no one suspected the
father of three might be suffering from
Cove in 1900 he went back to the
hospital days later and was put into
intensive care by the time a test
confirmed the 51 year olds had the virus
he was dead unfortunately
do well Huntington had chronic leukemia
so he was more vulnerable than most of
the illness but what's most concerning
his officials have no idea how he got it
in Quebec 82 year old Mariette Tremblay
died after contact with a recent
traveler on Facebook her family asked
that people follow recommendations to
stay home we didn't get a chance to save
grandma but you have the chance to make
a difference now that we know I just
kept sleeping and coughing and not
having any appetite 74 year old Karen
Schumacher was awaiting test results for
kovin 19 when she finally called 911
woman developed a cough weeks after
returning from a cruise but her daughter
says it was days before doctors were
able to confirm the Schumacher had Cove
819 the isolation was not only was not
getting any answers she was feeling
really really sick really fast I
remember asking one of the nurses when I
was first at the hospital and I ended I
from this because that was my fear
Schumacher spent several days in
hospital on oxygen before her condition
improved her diagnosis was confirmed
just before she was cleared to go home
she's now recovering in isolation and
sure of how long she'll have to stay
there Heather Eric's West Global News
Calgary
scrubs are the new capes next the global
gratitude for health care heroes
among those at greatest risk from this
virus or the people who take care of us
when the rest of us stay home they go to
work to honor their dedication there are
calls for Canadians to open their
windows or step outside to applaud all
the doctors nurses and health care
workers Eric Sorenson reports on the
essential workers called to duty in this
dangerous time their jobs are difficult
in ordinary times frontline workers
overlooked for the comfort they bring
and the risks they take in this
extraordinary moment we are reminded of
their simple bravery in China dr. Lee
wen Liang sent out the early warning
then stood his ground in the face of
kovat 19 and then died the outpouring
for him a recognition of the sacrifice
that would soon be required all over the
world in this country health workers are
answering that call nurses in Ontario
retired part-time full-time more than
4,000 have responded frontline workers
warned us the health care system wasn't
fully ready for this but now that a
pandemic is upon us they're swallowing
their frustration and staring down their
fears I think there is fear I think
that's normal but I also think that
there's a sense of duty this is what we
trained for remember the first
responders on 911 when people fled the
Twin Towers firefighters ran in today
those are the health care workers in
Italy more than 2,600 have been infected
in the hardest hit countries of Europe
Italy Spain Paris the appreciation has
been genuine and spontaneous the troops
going to this war are inspiring
musicians you and me we still hear from
Bono to yo-yo ma
the doctors nurses social workers
emergency responders all of them know
what they're getting into and any one of
us could soon find ourselves looking up
from a bed to say help me and thank you
for being here
Eric Sorensen Global News it's clear
we're at the start of something we've
never lived through before and it will
touch all of us in some way from the
Prime Minister and self-isolation to the
families grieving their loved ones
the first Canadians to die from kovat 19
we know there will be more we know this
virus is going to be with us for months
we'll all find ways to cope and to adapt
and we at Global News are going to be
going through it with you covering every
angle and every night my goal is to
leave you with something to nurture your
soul tonight it's the kids words of hope
doodles rainbows and funny faces they're
popping up on windows everywhere the
hashtag is from my window flashes of
optimism we all need right now thanks
for watching and take care of yourself
bye-bye
[Music]